Anthony Swofford was an infantryman in the Marines back during the 1991 Gulf War. And we asked him to watch the television coverage for us once this war got under way and tell us his impressions.
安东尼·斯沃福德在1991年海湾战争期间曾是海军陆战队的一名步兵。战争一打响，我们就请他为我们观看电视报道，并告诉我们他的感想。
Oh I'm thinking it's strange to be in my living room this time. And this morning there was the first scenes of the oil well fires burning as some Marines are up near them. And that brought the whole scene pretty close to me.
哦，我觉得这次在自己的客厅里看这些报道感觉很奇怪。今天早上，第一幕出现了油井大火燃烧的场景，一些海军陆战队员就在附近。这让整个场景离我非常近。
For a civilian watching this coverage today, I have to say, I feel like, oh, I'm right there. It feels so real. For you watching this coverage, does it all seemed fantastically fake?
对于今天观看这些报道的平民来说，我不得不说，我感觉就像身临其境。这感觉太真实了。对于你来说，看着这些报道，这一切看起来是否极其虚假？
Yeah, it does. It feels made up and scripted.
是的，确实如此。感觉像是编造和写好的剧本。
Now you brought along a recording of some of the things you taped off TV. Let's just play one of those.
你带了一些从电视上录下来的片段。让我们放一段来看看。
There's this one great scene of the wild man on CNN who-- he's moving with the seventh cavalry, and he's talking about "great waves of steel crushing the Iraqis."
CNN上那个狂人有一个很棒的场景——他正随第七骑兵团行动，他说着“钢铁巨浪正碾碎伊拉克人”。
You don't sleep. You really don't sleep out here. Of course you're on an adrenaline high. But racing across the desert, you know that you're traveling toward the jaws of what could be a major military battle.
你不睡觉。你在这里真的没法睡觉。当然，你正处于肾上腺素飙升的状态。但在沙漠中疾驰时，你知道你正驶向一场可能成为重大军事战役的深渊。
He's dramatically narrating what currently from the video is a totally un-dramatic and incredibly common event, which is vehicles moving across the desert. But he's projecting this romantic vision of what the battle will be.
他正在戏剧性地描述当前视频中一个完全不具戏剧性且极其普通的事件，即车辆在沙漠中移动。但他正在投射一种对战斗将会是什么样的浪漫愿景。
Then the army is going to kill them. Their goal is to find the enemy, grab him by the nose they say. And this is according to one senior officer, after grabbing him by the nose, we don't let the Iraqis go anywhere. The seventh cavalry's mission is to find the Iraqis and to persuade them to give up. And if they don't give up, then they will be pounded, according to the officers we're travelling with.
然后军队要干掉他们。他们的目标是找到敌人，用他们的话说，抓住他的鼻子。这是一位高级军官说的，抓住鼻子后，我们就不会让伊拉克人逃掉。第七骑兵团的任务是找到伊拉克人并说服他们投降。随行的军官们说，如果他们不投降，就会遭到重击。
Just because the tanks are barreling across the desert on their way to Baghdad, that doesn't mean that they're going to roll over and grab the enemy by the nose.
仅仅因为坦克在前往巴格达的路上疾驰穿越沙漠，并不意味着他们就会直接冲过去抓住敌人的鼻子。
This would be an example of one of those moments that you find to be completely fake.
这会是你认为完全虚假的时刻之一吗？
Yeah completely fake.
是的，完全虚假。
By the way this is This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. This guy Anthony Swofford has been on our program before, reading from his memoir about fighting in the Persian gulf war, which is called Jarhead . He says he finds it hard to watch the coverage of this war now. He thinks it's fine for camera crews to go out with the soldiers and all, but he says that to him, it just seems voyeuristic in this way that just gives him the creeps. In battle, he says, you're completely naked in this way. It's so extreme. And he says the cameras can't really capture what it's like to be there anyway.
顺便说一下，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。安东尼·斯沃福德之前上过我们的节目，朗读了他关于波斯湾战争战斗的回忆录《Jarhead》。他说现在很难看这些关于战争的报道。他认为摄像组跟随士兵出去报道没问题，但他觉得这种方式让他感到一种偷窥的毛骨悚然。他说，在战斗中，你是以这种方式完全赤裸的。这太极端了。而且他说摄像机无论如何都无法真正捕捉到身临其境的感觉。
The missing element thus far is fear and the unknown. Everything seems certain when there's a camera filming this.
目前缺失的元素是恐惧和未知。当有摄像机在拍摄时，一切似乎都是确定的。
You've written about how you and the other Marines during the Persian Gulf War who you were with were told to say pretty much next to nothing to reporters. Keep everything positive. You were given little scripts to say. When you watch the interviews that are now being broadcast on TV, do you feel like you're seeing soldiers spinning the way that you were trained to?
你曾写过在波斯湾战争期间，你和身边的其他海军陆战队员被告知几乎什么都不要对记者说。保持一切积极向上。你们被给了简短的脚本。当你观看现在电视上播出的采访时，你是否觉得你看到的士兵们在按照你们被训练的方式进行“公关”？
Oh I'm certain of it. What's coming out of their mouths is scripted. And it's what they're asked to say. And it's also part of what they're asked to believe, and they believe some of it. But--
哦，我对此很确定。他们嘴里说出来的话都是写好的。这是他们被要求说的内容。这也是他们被要求相信的内容的一部分，他们确实相信其中一些。但是——
Can you think of any particular moment where you've seen somebody talking and you thought, yeah, that's right. That's just the line we give them.
你能想到任何特定的时刻，你看到有人说话，然后心想，是的，没错。那就是我们给他们的说辞。
Yeah, well this morning there was an embed sitting with a Marine. And they were a forward force that had had nine gas calls over the evening. And having nine false gas calls is incredibly frustrating, and it pisses you off. And you're cussing. You're saying who's that idiot who called gas again? I'm tired of putting this thing on.
是的，今天早上有个随军记者和一个海军陆战队员坐在一起。他们是一支前沿部队，整个晚上接到了九次毒气警报。经历九次虚假的毒气警报是非常令人沮丧的，这会让你火冒三丈。你会骂人。你会说，又是哪个白痴发出的毒气警报？我厌倦了戴这个东西。
Calling gas meaning somebody said gas is incoming and so put on your gas gear.
发出毒气警报意味着有人说毒气正在袭来，所以要戴上防毒装备。
Yeah, gas is incoming. So the reporter asked the young marine that. "How are you feeling? We've put our gas masks on nine times now? How does this make you feel? And the young guy said, "It's just what we do. We put our gas masks on." That's all he's going to give. He's not going to say, "Oh this sucks man. I'm tired of putting this thing on."
是的，毒气袭来。所以那个记者问那个年轻的海军陆战队员：“你感觉如何？我们现在已经九次戴上防毒面具了？这让你感觉怎么样？”那个年轻人说：“这就是我们该做的。我们戴上防毒面具。”他只会说这些。他不会说：“哦，这糟透了伙计。我厌倦戴这玩意儿了。”
Well today on our radio program, as bombs go off and soldiers are on the move, we have stories about this war that's just starting. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today in six acts. David Sedaris files for us from Paris. Sarah Vowell tells the story of the first time that the United States went overseas and attacked a country that had not attacked us first, a country where 100 years later, things are still pretty dreadful.
今天在我们的广播节目中，随着炸弹爆炸和士兵们开始行动，我们带来了关于这场刚刚开始的战争的故事。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目分六幕。大卫·塞达里斯为我们从巴黎发来报道。莎拉·沃威尔讲述了美国第一次去海外攻击一个并未先攻击我们的国家的故事，这是一个100年后情况依然相当糟糕的国家。
In preparation for today's show, we gave out audio recorders to a few soldiers who are part of the invasion force going into Iraq. We probably will not get the recordings back and on the air for you for a few months. But we do have one first person account of what's happening, an email from one soldier. Plus other stores trying to make sense of what is happening right now. Stay with us.
为了准备今天的节目，我们分发了一些录音机给几名即将进入伊拉克的入侵部队士兵。我们可能要几个月后才能拿回这些录音并播出。但我们确实有一个关于正在发生什么的亲身叙述，来自一名士兵的电子邮件。此外，还有其他试图理清当下局势的报道。请继续收听。
Act One, Bombs Over Baghdad. When it comes to the massive bombing of Baghdad that has started, all of us following the news heard from the US military. We've heard from reporters in Baghdad. But a while back I spoke with an Iraqi named Issam Shukri, who lived in Baghdad during the first Persian Gulf War. And he talked about what it was like to despise Saddam Hussein, but also not be so crazy about getting bombed by the United States. He remembers clearly how he learned that war had started back then.
第一幕，巴格达上空的炸弹。说到已经开始的对巴格达的大规模轰炸，我们所有关注新闻的人都听到了来自美军的消息。我们听到了巴格达记者的报道。但不久前，我采访了一位名叫伊萨姆·舒克里的伊拉克人，他在第一次波斯湾战争期间住在巴格达。他谈到了既鄙视萨达姆·侯赛因，又不太喜欢被美国轰炸是什么感觉。他清楚地记得那时他是如何得知战争开始的。
Me and my wife used to work in two different rooms in the same building. And she always listened to a Kuwaiti station, the national Kuwaiti station, because it has some more fun songs and mixture of songs and stuff like that. But anyway, so she was trying to find that station but she couldn't. And she said, "Issam, it seems there is something wrong with the radio. I can't find that station." So I start to flip through the stations, and I put it on our Baghdad station. And boy, I started to hear the marches and the military music.
我和妻子过去在同一栋楼的两个房间工作。她总是听一个科威特电台，国家科威特电台，因为那里有更多有趣的歌曲和混合曲目之类的东西。但总之，她试图找那个电台，但找不到。她说：“伊萨姆，收音机好像出了点问题。我找不到那个台。”所以我开始切换电台，调到了我们的巴格达电台。天哪，我开始听到进行曲和军事音乐。
Did that automatically mean you knew that there was trouble?
那是否自动意味着你知道出事了？
Yes, that was the government's announcement in music to times of trouble. I heard about the invasion by dashing out to the street. And I said, what happened? And people in a lower voice, "Well Saddam invaded Kuwait. And he's calling people to go and fight over there at the front." And I sort of stroked my head, and I said, not again.
是的，那是政府在困难时期用音乐发出的公告。我通过冲到街上得知了入侵的消息。我问发生了什么事？人们低声说：“好吧，萨达姆入侵了科威特。他正在号召人们去前线战斗。”我摸了摸头说，不会吧，又是这样。
Had you served in the Iran Iraq war?
你参加过两伊战争吗？
Yes, I served for three years actually.
是的，实际上我服役了三年。
In that war of course, an incredibly bloody war, estimates of the dead range up to 1.5 million. Iraq used chemical weapons in the war. Could you talk about what it felt like to know that you were being called up again to fight in this conflict for somebody who you didn't support?
在那场战争中，当然是一场极其血腥的战争，死亡人数估计高达150万。伊拉克在战争中使用了化学武器。你能谈谈得知自己再次被征召去为你不支持的人打仗是什么感觉吗？
Well, I don't know. Ira, it's the most individualistic as well as a collective miserable experience you will ever have. Because you are facing actually not one enemy. You are facing two enemies: one in your back, and one in your face. And when you turn to run away, you see the back enemy trying to shoot you.
嗯，我不知道。艾拉，这是你所能拥有的最个人化也是最集体化的悲惨经历。因为你面对的实际上不是一个敌人。你面对两个敌人：一个在背后，一个在面前。当你转身逃跑时，你会看到背后的敌人试图射杀你。
That is your--
那是你的——
That is the government of Iraq, right. I couldn't picture myself putting on the same uniform and fighting for a bloody regime again. So that was my feeling. And the next day, I had to go to that military center and join the forces. But as I was an architect, I was actually allocated to the back of the front, inside the city of Baghdad.
那是伊拉克政府，没错。我无法想象自己穿上同样的制服再次为一个血腥的政权而战。所以这就是我的感受。第二天，我不得不去那个军事中心加入部队。但由于我是一名建筑师，我实际上被分配到了前线后方，巴格达市内部。
Oh, so you were very lucky?
哦，所以你很幸运？
I was actually. But some of my classmates were sent to out to the front. And some of them faced their deaths there. They were killed.
确实如此。但我的一些同学被派到了前线。他们中的一些人在那里面对了死亡。他们被杀害了。
Did they have the same kinds of feelings about Saddam that you did, that they didn't like the regime?
他们对萨达姆是否有和你一样的感觉，即他们不喜欢那个政权？
Ira, 100%. 100% I will tell you.
艾拉，100%。我可以100%告诉你。
Talk about the air strikes. Could you talk about what that was like? You were in Baghdad when the US started its 38 day air campaign against Iraq.
谈谈空袭吧。你能谈谈那是什么感觉吗？当美国开始对伊拉克进行为期38天的空中战役时，你就在巴格达。
Right. I was in my home with my wife and my three year old son. And I was renovating my house. I was like two years, three years married to my wife. And I was dividing my family home into two little homes. One is for my sister, and one is for my family. And as a show of emotional support, we all slept-- we had mattresses on the floor in my living room, which had doors open because I was renovating at the time. I've brought a lot of paint to paint my living room. So anyway, we slept on that night, and the night of the 17 of January, in my living room. And we kissed each other, and we fell asleep.
对。我当时和妻子及三岁的儿子在家里。我正在翻修房子。我和妻子结婚也就两三年吧。我正在把我的家庭住宅分成两个小房子。一个是给我姐姐的，一个是给我家人的。为了表示情感上的支持，我们都睡在客厅里，我们在地板上铺了床垫，因为当时我在装修，门是开着的。我买了很多油漆来刷我的客厅。所以总之，那晚，1月17日的那晚，我们睡在客厅里。我们吻了对方，然后睡着了。
And exactly at 2:00 AM, we all woke up and the ground was shaking violently. And it was like a deep, deep echo happening coming down from the ground. And the streetlights were on at the time. And in five minutes, all the lights were out. And at that minute, we were certain that this is the war, and we're back again. We are facing death all over again. I personally, Ira, I'm not ashamed of this. I started to shake. My hands couldn't hold anything. I grabbed my--
就在凌晨2点，我们都醒了，地面在剧烈震动。那就像是从地面传来的一种深深的、深深的回声。当时街灯还亮着。五分钟后，所有的灯都熄灭了。那一刻，我们确信这就是战争，我们又回到了原点。我们再次面临死亡。我个人，艾拉，我对此并不羞愧。我开始发抖。我的手拿不住任何东西。我抓住了我的——
Take a second.
休息一会儿。
I grabbed my little kid, and he was crying. He didn't know what was happening. I remember my son when he heard the B52 over his head. I put my hand on his heart, and I felt his heart bumping like crazy. And ironically, again I went to the washroom like five, six times in five minutes. You know when you have this stress? I needed to go to the washroom.
我抓住了我的小儿子，他在哭。他不知道发生了什么事。我记得我儿子听到头顶上的B52轰炸机声时。我把手放在他的心口，感觉到他的心脏在疯狂跳动。讽刺的是，我又是五分钟内去了五六次厕所。你知道那种压力吗？我需要去厕所。
As mundane as this is, but I need to tell the Americans about it. The fear is very, very frightening when you're expecting your death. It's much more frightening when it happens suddenly, if you're asleep or if you're embarking on your work or whatever. But when you're expecting it minute by minute, and second by second sometimes, it becomes like torture.
虽然这很世俗，但我需要告诉美国人。当你期待死亡时，那种恐惧是非常非常可怕的。当它突然发生时，如果你在睡觉，或者如果你正在忙着你的工作之类的，那会更可怕。但当你每分钟、每秒钟都在期待它时，它有时会变成一种折磨。
So we were literally tortured. And we started to wonder with the streets. I looked around in my neighborhood-- and by the way our neighborhood looks pretty much like any American or Canadian neighborhood: row houses or individual homes with front yards and very nicely done. And people that have the same qualities of life. The difference is that they live in constant fear.
所以我们简直是在受折磨。我们开始在街道上徘徊。我环顾我的社区——顺便说一句，我们的社区看起来很像任何美国或加拿大的社区：排屋或带前院的独立住宅，非常漂亮。人们拥有同样的品质生活。不同的是他们生活在持续的恐惧中。
And you were with your three year old boy.
你当时和你的三岁儿子在一起。
Right, and well actually, I was very worried about this guy because he was very young. And when fear-- when you start your life by experiencing fear and bombing, it would leave scars in your soul for the rest of your life. And I think he's fine now, but he kept asking me, "Why are they doing this to us? What have we done?" And I couldn't find the right answer because he was very young at the time. I couldn't go into deep political analysis of what's going on. But I told him, "There is a bad guy who did something wrong. And there are some judges of the world who wanted to take the law in their hands. And then they came and punished him." And then I stopped for one second. But then he said, "But they are punishing us. But we are scared. He's not scared."
对，好吧，实际上，我非常担心这个家伙，因为他太小了。当你通过经历恐惧和轰炸来开始你的人生时，它会在你的灵魂中留下伤疤，伴随你的余生。我想他现在没事了，但他不停地问我：“他们为什么要这样对我们？我们做错了什么？”我找不到正确的答案，因为他当时太小了。我无法深入分析正在发生的政治情况。但我告诉他：“有一个坏人做错了事。还有一些世界的法官想把法律掌握在自己手中。于是他们来了，惩罚了他。”我停顿了一秒钟。但他接着说：“但他们正在惩罚我们。我们很害怕。他不害怕。”
Did he ask why are they bombing all of us if they're just trying to get this bad man?
他有没有问，如果他们只是想抓住这个坏人，为什么要轰炸我们所有人？
Well Ira, I didn't try to justify what the American forces were doing, to tell you the truth. I'm not going to polish my words. I told him that-- after days and days of bombing, I first told him that, "Well there are some judges who are going to catch this man. And he's an outlaw, and they're going to put him in jail." I tried to make things like a story to his age.
好吧，艾拉，老实说，我并没有试图为美军的所作所为辩解。我不会粉饰我的言辞。我告诉他——在轰炸了几天之后，我最初告诉他，“有一些法官要去抓住这个人。他是个罪犯，他们要把他关进监狱。”我试图把事情编成适合他年龄的故事。
And then after that, I started to feel frustrated myself because I saw people slaughtered in front of my eyes. And Saddam comes out on the screen laughing with his ugly, ugly face. So I started to tell him, "Well those judges are sometimes more severe, and sometimes they hit hard. The people themselves will suffer some injuries, but again, that's OK. Probably in the end they will catch him." But it never happened. And neither in Iraq nor in Afghanistan, nor anywhere in the world.
在那之后，我自己开始感到沮丧，因为我亲眼看到人们被屠杀。而萨达姆出现在屏幕上，用他那丑陋、丑陋的面孔大笑。所以我开始告诉他，“嗯，那些法官有时更严厉，有时他们打击得很重。人们自己会遭受一些伤害，但没关系。可能最终他们会抓住他。”但这从未发生过。无论是在伊拉克，还是在阿富汗，还是在世界上的任何地方。
Was there a part of you which hoped that the Americans would succeed and liberate Iraq from Saddam Hussein.
你内心有没有一部分希望美国能成功并将伊拉克从萨达姆·侯赛因手中解放出来？
To tell you the truth, I hoped for that. I hoped for that. But I felt deep, deep in heart that they're not going to catch this person. I've always doubted that, and not only me. All the people in Iraq doubted that because there's always history that tells you lessons. And there is the fresh memory when Saddam bombed chemically, used the chemical weapons against Halabcha, which is a northern, very, very peaceful city in 1988, and killed 5,000 people in two hours. Nobody in the West raised a finger. Nobody called him a terrorist. Nobody called him a tyrant.
老实说，我希望那样。我希望那样。但我内心深处感到他们不会抓住这个人。我一直对此表示怀疑，不仅是我。伊拉克的所有人都怀疑这一点，因为历史总是给你教训。还有新鲜的记忆，当萨达姆在1988年使用化学武器针对哈拉布贾时，那是一个非常、非常宁静的北部城市，在两小时内杀死了5000人。西方没有一个人动过手指。没有一个人称他为恐怖分子。没有一个人称他为暴君。
But when he touched a state that is a strong ally to the West, a state that's very rich in oil, everybody-- So we didn't really trust the West. It's a feeling that those people do not care about other nations.
但当他触碰了一个作为西方坚定盟友的国家，一个盛产石油的国家，每个人——所以我们并没有真正信任西方。这是一种感觉，即那些人并不关心其他国家。
And what did you think about the United States at that time? Did you hate the United States for the bombing? Did you feel a mix of feelings about it because you hoped that they would come in?
你当时是怎么看美国的？你因为轰炸而恨美国吗？你是否因为希望他们进入而感到心情复杂？
I didn't like the United States as a government, as a military force, not the people. I saw cruise missiles falling on buildings, but some of these buildings were inhabited by civilians. So I do not hate. I do not hate. I don't like to use this word, but I was mad. I was angry at the United States government because it uses a lot of force, a lot of force, inhuman force to punish very poor people.
我不喜欢美国作为一个政府，作为一支军事力量，而不是人民。我看到巡航导弹落在建筑物上，但其中一些建筑物里住着平民。所以我并不恨。我不喜欢用这个词，但我很生气。我生美国政府的气，因为它使用大量的武力，大量不人道的武力来惩罚非常贫穷的人。
And were you also angry at Saddam for putting you all in this position?
你也生萨达姆的气，因为他把你们所有人都置于这种境地吗？
Oh, in that respect, we hated Saddam. I would definitely use that word.
哦，在那方面，我们恨萨达姆。我肯定会用那个词。
Issam Shukri is watching the war from his home in Toronto, where he lives and works as an architect. He has two sisters, four aunts and uncles and many nieces and nephews in Baghdad. He last talked with them all a few days ago. He hasn't been able to reach them since because the phones have been bad. He doesn't know how they're doing.
伊萨姆·舒克里正在多伦多的家中观看这场战争，他在那里生活并担任建筑师。他在巴格达有两个姐姐，四个叔叔和阿姨，还有许多侄子和侄女。他几天前最后一次和他们所有人谈过。从那以后，由于电话线路不好，他一直没能联系上他们。他不知道他们现在怎么样了。
Act Two. Over the last few weeks, our program has been in contact with a number of American soldiers in this war. One of the ones who expressed an interest in giving an account of what is happening to him is first lieutenant Tice Ridley. He's been in the army for seven years. He's 30 years old. He's the one we're able to put on the air this week because he's the one who's continued to have access to email. He's someone whose job is to deal with the press. He's a public relations officer at the Coalition Press Information Center in Kuwait City.
第二幕。在过去的几周里，我们的节目一直与这场战争中的一些美国士兵保持联系。其中一位表示有兴趣讲述他身上发生的事情的是泰斯·里德利中尉。他在军队呆了七年。他今年30岁。他是我们本周能安排上节目的人，因为他一直在使用电子邮件。他的工作是与媒体打交道。他是科威特城联军新闻中心的一名公关官。
What you're about to hear are taken from the emails that he has sent to friends and family, and emails he has sent to our program. We asked him to stay away from the official army stories that he deals with in his job and just talk about what it's like to be there. His emails are read for us by actor Tom Wright.
你们接下来要听到的内容摘自他发给朋友和家人的电子邮件，以及他发给我们节目的邮件。我们要求他避开他在工作中处理的那些官方军队故事，只谈谈身临其境是什么感觉。他的电子邮件由演员汤姆·赖特为我们朗读。
February 27, 2003. Dear friends and family. Last night we arrived in Kuwait City, which is nine hours ahead of you guys so I'm actually living in the future. If you want to know what happens, just let me know. When we got off the plane, it still looked a lot like Texas, but there was no mistaking where we were. There were soldiers with weapons everywhere. The buses we rode from the airport in had curtains covering all the windows to prevent sniper fire. And we were escorted by soldiers with fully loaded, crew-served weapons, really big guns mounted on their vehicles. Sniper fire is common here.
2003年2月27日。亲爱的朋友和家人。昨晚我们到达了科威特城，这里比你们快9个小时，所以我实际上生活在未来。如果你想知道会发生什么，告诉我。当我们下飞机时，它看起来还是很像德克萨斯州，但毫无疑问我们身在何处。到处都是带着武器的士兵。我们乘坐的从机场出来的巴士上，窗户都挂着帘子以防止狙击手射击。我们由配备全套弹药、车载机组武器的士兵护送，车上装载着非常大的枪支。狙击手射击在这里很常见。
On our first night, my vehicle broke down during a convoy, and the security force with those big guns was unable to turn around to assist my driver, a 19 year old private, and me. We'd been briefed on what to do, but the plan failed because security was unable to stop or turn around right away. We were sitting there alone, in a foreign land with street signs in Arabic, not knowing whom to trust. What do you do?
第一天晚上，我的车在车队中抛锚了，带着那些大枪的安保部队无法掉头来协助我和我的司机（一名19岁的一等兵）。我们被告知该怎么做，但计划失败了，因为安保无法立即停止或转弯。我们就坐在那里，在一个陌生的国度，路标都是阿拉伯文，不知道该信任谁。你该怎么办？
After assessing the situation, it was my decision to keep moving no matter how slow. I didn't want us to appear to be an easy sniper target. After about 15 minutes, but what seemed like an eternity, the security force was able to turn around and catch up with us, prepare the vehicle and guide us back into the convoy.
评估情况后，我决定继续前进，无论多慢。我不想让我们看起来像个容易被狙击的目标。大约15分钟后，感觉像是一个世纪，安保部队能够掉头赶上我们，修理车辆并引导我们回到车队。
After we'd been returned to our comfort zone with the rest of our convoy, I asked my driver if he had been scared. And initially, he said no. He then asked me if I had been afraid. I replied, "Yeah, I was scared as hell." I told him that scared is good, as long as you don't let panic set in, because fear will keep you alert and alive. I saw that in some movie somewhere, but I think it's true. The private then told me that he had been afraid but didn't want me to know. I would go to war with a solider like that any day. Oh wait, we're already here.
回到车队和其他人在一起后，我问我的司机他是否害怕。起初，他说没有。然后他问我是否害怕。我回答说：“是的，我害怕得要命。”我告诉他，害怕是好事，只要你不让恐慌蔓延，因为恐惧会让你保持警觉并活下去。我从某部电影里看到过这个，但我认为这是真的。那个一等兵随后告诉我，他确实害怕，但不想让我知道。我随时愿意与这样的士兵一起去打仗。哦等等，我们已经在这里了。
Friday, March 7, 2003. Around 5:00, Murphy showed his ugly little head and the phone started ringing. A soldier was injured pretty badly in an accident, and I got the message. It's not the first time I've gotten a message of this nature, but it was the first time I looked at the name. That made a world of difference. It was no one I knew, but looking at a name and a hometown personalized it. That is something I have to learn to deal with.
2003年3月7日，星期五。大约5点钟，墨菲定律显现，电话开始响起。一名士兵在事故中受了重伤，我收到了消息。这不是我第一次收到这种性质的消息，但这是我第一次看到名字。这带来了巨大的不同。那不是我认识的人，但看着一个名字和一个家乡，这让人感觉真实了。这是我必须学会面对的事情。
Monday, March 17, 2003. I met Ted Koppel the other day. Nice guy, little worn-looking though. I told him to have his people call my people and maybe, just maybe, we could do lunch after the war. Yesterday I was interviewed by Jay Levine of Channel 2, Chicago. That was cool. I've received email from some of you saying that you saw the interview. He asked me how I felt about the protesters and political debate. What I really wanted to say was, "Those [BLEEP] need to go to Saddam Hussein's house and try their protesting in front of one of his billion dollar palaces. Or maybe they can go sing Kumbaya with the bastard. And just maybe he'll stop mass murdering, invading his neighbors and gassing people.
2003年3月17日，星期一。我前几天见到了泰德·科佩尔。好人，不过看起来有点疲惫。我告诉他让他的人联系我的人，也许，只是也许，我们可以在战后一起吃午饭。昨天我接受了芝加哥第2频道杰伊·莱文的采访。那很酷。我收到一些你们的电子邮件说你们看到了采访。他问我对抗议者和政治辩论有什么感觉。我真正想说的是：“那些[哔——]应该去萨达姆·侯赛因家，尝试在他那十亿美金的宫殿前抗议。或者也许他们可以去和那个混蛋唱《Kumbaya》。也许他就会停止大规模屠杀、入侵邻国和毒气杀人。”
As far as the political debate goes, I think those countries that keep saying more time don't have soldiers sitting in the desert longing to be with their families. Not that we're war mongers, but most of us didn't give up our lives so that we could come to the desert to play dominoes. Hell, I don't even know how to play freaking dominoes.
就政治辩论而言，我认为那些一直说需要更多时间的国家，并没有士兵坐在沙漠里渴望与家人团聚。并不是我们好战，但我们大多数人放弃生活来到沙漠不是为了打多米诺骨牌。见鬼，我甚至不知道怎么玩该死的多米诺骨牌。
However, while wearing the uniform, I represent the United States Army, so I had to keep it professional and say, "I really don't think about it much." With that in mind, I must say farewell my friends. Please think about these things as you form your opinions on this possible war. We see a lot of protest on the news here, but if you see someone protesting, ask them if they know the history. And if so, why aren't they protesting Saddam Hussein? Love you all, Tice. PS, if you haven't done already, I would fill up my gas tank today if I were you.
然而，穿着这身制服，我代表美国陆军，所以我必须保持专业，说：“我真的没怎么想过这件事。”考虑到这一点，我必须向朋友们告别了。请在形成对这场潜在战争的看法时考虑这些事情。我们在这里的新闻上看到了很多抗议，但如果你看到有人在抗议，问问他们是否了解历史。如果是这样，为什么他们不去抗议萨达姆·侯赛因？爱你们所有人，泰斯。附：如果你们还没做，我建议今天去把油箱加满。
Tuesday, March 18, 2003. A little over 24 hours ago, President George W. Bush gave a powerful speech, and we all wondered if the wait was over. 48 hours was his answer, and I actually breathed a sigh of relief. This is my first war, and in my inexperience, I thought that as soon as the President left the podium, planes would start flying overhead and the war would have begun. He gave them 48 hours.
2003年3月18日，星期二。大约24小时前，乔治·W·布什总统发表了一场强有力的演讲，我们都在想等待是否结束了。48小时是他的回答，我实际上松了一口气。这是我的第一场战争，由于我经验不足，我以为总统一下讲台，飞机就会开始在头顶飞过，战争就开始了。他给了他们48小时。
Thursday, March 20, 2003. It is now 2:55 on the morning of March 20. The 48 hour deadline is up in one hour and five minutes, and all's quiet. One of the first things I was told as I started my shift was that Iraq had placed artillery pieces along the border with Kuwait within striking distance of us. This was a definite concern of ours, and you could see by the mood that it was at the back of everyone's mind. The initial fear is of a direct hit, but even if we didn't get hit directly, the chemical vapors might drift our way. Tracy and I read from the Bible together every night. We also take turns reading the 91st Psalm to each other. That's a long story. But a unit from World War Two read that psalm every day together, and while all the other units around them were being wiped out, none of them got a scratch.
2003年3月20日，星期四。现在是3月20日凌晨2点55分。48小时的最后期限还有一小时五分钟，一切都很安静。我开始轮班时被告知的第一件事是，伊拉克在与科威特的边界沿线部署了火炮，在我们的打击范围内。这绝对是我们关注的问题，你可以从情绪上看出来，每个人心底都在担心这个。最初的恐惧是遭到直接打击，但即使我们没有被直接击中，化学蒸汽也可能漂到我们这边。特蕾西和我每天晚上一起读圣经。我们还轮流为对方读《诗篇》第91篇。那是个长故事。但二战中的一个部队每天一起读那篇诗篇，虽然他们周围所有的其他部队都被消灭了，但他们没有一个人受点伤。
At approximately 22:00, Tracy came down for our nightly reading of the 91st Psalm. As I reentered the office, there was a flurry of phone calls. We found out that the artillery pieces that were within range of us had been destroyed by coalition air forces. The Air Force officer that happened to be in the section at the time yelled, "The Air Force is always saving you guy's asses." The information was soon confirmed, and we breathed a sigh of relief. Also, we heard that 17 Iraqi soldiers had turned themselves in. We were trying to get confirmation. My first thought was, 17 down and only 400,000 to go.
大约22点，特蕾西下来进行我们每晚的《诗篇》第91篇阅读。当我重新进入办公室时，一阵电话铃声响了。我们发现，在我们的打击范围内的火炮已被联军空军摧毁。当时恰好在部门里的空军军官大喊：“空军总是救你们这些人的屁股。”消息很快得到了确认，我们松了一口气。此外，我们听说有17名伊拉克士兵投降了。我们正在试图确认。我的第一个念头是，搞定了17个，还有40万个。
Tom Wright, reading the letters of first lieutenant Tice Ridley in Kuwait City. Coming up, David Sedaris reports from France, Sarah Vowell, and some lessons of war from thousands of years ago. How people thought about war back then, how we might think about it now. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
汤姆·赖特朗读泰斯·里德利中尉在科威特城的信件。接下来，大卫·塞达里斯从法国发回报道，莎拉·沃威尔，还有一些几千年前的战争教训。那时的人们是如何看待战争的，我们现在可能如何看待它。稍后，芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Balloon Goes Up, stories about this new war with Iraq. Much of Europe and the Arab world still oppose this war. Protests continue. Is the world just going to hate the United States now in some way we've never seen before in our lifetimes? Well, writer David Sedaris lives in one of the countries that oppose military action most fiercely, France. He says the answer to that question is complicated.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，气球升空，关于这场与伊拉克新战争的故事。欧洲和阿拉伯世界的大部分地区仍然反对这场战争。抗议仍在继续。世界是否会因为某种我们一生中从未见过的原因而恨美国？好吧，作家大卫·塞达里斯住在一个最强烈反对军事行动的国家——法国。他说这个问题的答案很复杂。
For the past several weeks, I've been been getting these late night calls. The phone rings, and when I answer the person on the other end will say, "Thank God, are you all right?" I wonder how they knew I had the radio perched on the lip of the bathtub, and then I'll realize that they're talking about the French American thing, which is a lot nastier in the United States than it is here. The assumption is that, mirroring the cafeteria in the US House of Representatives, France has banished the word "American," retitling videos to read "Liberty Gigolo" or "Freedom Graffiti." But that's not the case. Neither are radio stations hiring bulldozers to flatten hamburgers and low-fat muffins and pictures of the American president.
在过去的几周里，我一直接到深夜电话。电话响了，当我接听时，另一端的人会说：“谢天谢地，你没事吧？”我想知道他们怎么知道我把收音机放在浴缸边缘，然后我意识到他们在谈论法美关系，这在美国比在这里要糟糕得多。假设是，反映美国众议院食堂的情况，法国已经禁止了“美国”这个词，把视频重新命名为“自由男妓”或“自由涂鸦”。但事实并非如此。电台也没有雇佣推土机来夷平汉堡包、低脂松饼和美国总统的照片。
The French people I know are saddened by the name calling, but not enough to touch a muffin or a hamburger, much less a picture of George Bush. On September 11, 2001, Jacques Chirac announced that we are all Americans. A year and a half later, things have changed. Chirac threatened to use his UN veto, and the Bush administration announced that it could no longer take this country seriously. But how seriously did the current administration ever take France?
我认识的法国人为这些谩骂感到难过，但还没到拒绝松饼或汉堡包的地步，更不用说乔治·布什的照片了。2001年9月11日，雅克·希拉克宣布我们都是美国人。一年半后，情况发生了变化。希拉克威胁要使用他的联合国否决权，布什政府宣布不能再认真对待这个国家。但现任政府曾经多认真地对待过法国呢？
While the Clinton ambassador was engaged and well regarded, Bush appointed a former fast food processor who does not even speak the language. Bush doesn't come to France to talk with Chirac. He goes to England to talk about Chirac. And every time he opens his mouth, he makes it just that much harder to hold your head up. While in the United States, the President might make his own kind of sense, to most of the outside world he sounds like a bully and a braggart. Here is a man who actually failed to win a popularity contest against Saddam Hussein. And that's Europe's fault?
当克林顿的驻法大使积极参与且备受尊重时，布什任命了一位甚至不会说法语的前快餐加工商。布什不去法国与希拉克交谈。他去英国谈论希拉克。而且他每次开口，都让抬起头变得更加困难。在美国，总统可能有他自己的道理，但在大多数外界看来，他听起来像个恶霸和吹牛大王。这里有一个实际上在人气竞赛中输给萨达姆·侯赛因的人。那是欧洲的错吗？
I'm told that France is dangerous now, that Americans are being spat upon. But neither me nor my friends have experienced any hostility whatsoever. Talk to a French person about the war, and they'll say that while they dislike the current administration, they understand there's a difference between the American people and the American President. Six Feet Under they love, Tony Blair they grudgingly respect, but George Bush, that's another matter. If I did not share their view, I suppose there might be some discussion, but I can't imagine that it would result in saliva.
有人告诉我法国现在很危险，美国人被唾弃。但我和我的朋友都没有经历过任何敌意。和法国人谈论战争，他们会说，虽然他们不喜欢现任政府，但他们明白美国人民和美国总统之间是有区别的。他们喜欢《六尺之下》，勉强尊重托尼·布莱尔，但乔治·布什是另一回事。如果我不赞同他们的观点，我想可能会有一些讨论，但我无法想象这会导致唾沫横飞。
I have an American friend who speaks French perfectly and leads tours of Paris. As late as February, her spring schedule was packed. Then one by one, all of her upcoming parties phoned to cancel saying it just didn't seem safe. The only exception was a man from Wyoming, who said he would come as long as my friend could arrange for an armed bodyguard who would accompany him and his family everywhere they went. My friend explained that guns were not really allowed in the Louvre. And after expressing shock, the man canceled.
我有一个美国朋友，她法语说得非常好，并带巴黎旅游团。直到2月，她的春季时间表都排满了。然后一个接一个，她所有的预定派对打电话取消，说感觉不安全。唯一的例外是来自怀俄明州的一个人，他说只要我的朋友能安排一名持枪保镖随身陪同他和他的家人，他就会来。我的朋友解释说卢浮宫里真的不允许携带枪支。在表达了震惊之后，那个人取消了行程。
I know Americans who have taken to identifying themselves as Canadians, but I'm always afraid that if I try it myself, the other person will have family there and ask me what part of Canada I'm from. There is nothing more pathetic than being ashamed of where you come from. I know this. Still, I look at the American President raising his fist on the front page of Le Monde , and I find myself wondering, is Sacajawea a province? What about Mandingo?
我认识一些美国人开始把自己标榜为加拿大人，但我总是害怕如果我自己尝试，对方可能有亲戚在那里，问我来自加拿大的哪个部分。没有什么比为你来自哪里感到羞耻更可悲的了。我知道这一点。尽管如此，我看着美国总统在《世界报》头版挥舞拳头，我发现自己想知道，萨卡加维亚是一个省吗？曼丁戈呢？
David Sedaris is the author of several books, including one about his life in France titled Me Talk Pretty One Day .
大卫·塞达里斯是多本书的作者，包括一本关于他在法国生活的回忆录《Me Talk Pretty One Day》。
Act Four, Fighting The Previous War. Sarah Vowell has this story about the first time the United States attacked a country that had not attacked us. The first time we invaded a country for the purposes of regime change, which was widely seen as an idealistic act freeing an oppressed people. Here she is.
第四幕，打上一场战争。莎拉·沃威尔讲述了关于美国第一次攻击一个没有攻击我们的国家的故事。这是我们第一次为了政权更迭的目的入侵一个国家，这被广泛视为一种解放被压迫人民的理想主义行为。她来了。
The congressman from New York said that the United States was right to invade another country in order to "correct the intolerable evils and set up in their place the institutions of enlightened government." The President, who believed we were entrusted with this war by the providence of God, said "It is not a trust we sought. It is a trust from which we will not flinch." An American citizen living in Europe among Europeans opposed to America going to war wrote home that, "it is a worthy thing to fight for one's freedom. It is another sight finer to fight for another man's."
来自纽约的国会议员说，美国入侵另一个国家是为了“纠正不可容忍的邪恶，并代之以开明的政府机构”是正确的。这位相信我们受上帝的指引去进行这场战争的总统说：“这不是我们寻求的信任。这不是我们将会退缩的信任。”一位住在欧洲、身处反对美国开战的欧洲人中间的美国公民写信回家说，“为一个人的自由而战是一件值得的事。为一个人的自由而战是另一件更美好的事。”
The President was William McKinley, the American citizen, Mark Twain, and the congressman was speaking at the turn of the 20th century and not the 21st. These were the country's good intentions in our first attempt at regime change, the Spanish American War. As the United States embarks on Operation Iraqi Freedom, it's worth looking back on the role we played in creating that bastion of 20th century democracy known as Cuba. American do-gooders fought to liberate the oppressed people of Cuba from the tyranny of Spain. And what can we learn? For starters, the war itself is a snap. It's when the guns get put away and the ink pens come out that the real headaches begin.
总统是威廉·麦金莱，这位美国公民是马克·吐温，而那位国会议员讲话的时间是在20世纪之交，而不是21世纪。这些是美国在第一次政权更迭尝试中的良好初衷，即美西战争。随着美国开始“伊拉克自由行动”，回顾我们在建立那个被称为古巴的20世纪民主堡垒中扮演的角色是值得的。美国的善意者为将受压迫的古巴人民从西班牙的暴政中解放出来而战。我们能学到什么？首先，战争本身轻而易举。当枪支收起，钢笔拿出来时，真正的头疼事才开始。
The Cuban people suffered at the hands of the Spanish in the 1890s, especially those who were rounded up into concentration camps. American newspapers sensationalized Spanish atrocities, stirring up an idealistic fad for Cuba libre on the part of the American people. The clincher, the hard proof of Spanish evil-doing, was one of those acts that in retrospect might not have happened at all. Historians still disagree.
古巴人民在1890年代遭受西班牙人的苦难，特别是那些被强行关进集中营的人。美国报纸大肆渲染西班牙的暴行，激起了美国人民对“自由古巴”的理想主义狂热。最终的结果，即西班牙邪恶行为的铁证，是回顾过去可能根本没有发生过的行为之一。历史学家仍然有分歧。
On February 15, 1898, the American battleship, The Maine, exploded in Havana harbor, killing 254 men. Remember the Maine? War boosters accused the Spanish of bombing the ship and shrieked for a declaration of war. In fact, the evidence was inconclusive then and remains so today. Some historians believe it may have been a freak accident, a coal fire that ignited explosives on board the ship. Just like today, President McKinley had to squeak around that pesky provision in the Constitution that says Congress shall declare war. Congress didn't actually approve the war until it was already under way, but still, it's nice to be asked.
1898年2月15日，美国战列舰“缅因号”在哈瓦那港爆炸，造成254人死亡。记住缅因号？战争推动者指责西班牙炸毁了船只，并尖叫着要求宣战。事实上，证据在当时是不确定的，今天仍然如此。一些历史学家认为这可能是一场离奇的事故，是煤火引燃了船上的炸药。就像今天一样，麦金莱总统不得不绕过宪法中那条令人讨厌的条款，即国会应宣战。国会实际上直到战争已经开始才批准，但即便如此，被询问一下还是不错的。
Then, as now, optional wars are fought because there are people in the government who really, really want to fight them. The Paul Wolfowitz of the McKinley administration was the assistant secretary of the Navy, one Theodore Roosevelt. He was part of a group of young wonks from various branches of the government who had been arguing that it was in the American interest to wrench Cuba from the clutches of Spain. They feared what would happen if the iffy Cuban rebels governed themselves. They wanted American companies to get a piece of the Cuban sugar business. And they thought Cuba would be a handy base of operations from which to get cracking on a canal they hoped to one day build in Central America.
那时，就像现在一样，选择性战争之所以被发动，是因为政府中有非常、非常想打仗的人。麦金莱政府的保罗·沃尔福威茨是海军助理部长，即西奥多·罗斯福。他是来自政府各个部门的一群年轻干部的成员，他们一直争辩说，将古巴从西班牙的魔爪中夺走符合美国利益。他们担心如果古巴反叛者自己统治会发生什么。他们希望美国公司能分得古巴糖业的一杯羹。而且他们认为古巴将是一个方便的行动基地，可以从中开始着手建设他们希望有一天能在中美洲建造的运河。
Roosevelt wanted all those things, but more than anything, he wanted to fight. He wanted to wear an outfit, I mean uniform. He wanted to use one of his favorite words, adventure. And he wanted these things so badly that once the US declared war on Spain, he resigned as assistant secretary of the Navy, ordered himself a custom-tailored uniform from Brooks Brothers and volunteered to fight as a comparatively lowly lieutenant colonel with the first US volunteer cavalry.
罗斯福想要所有这些东西，但最重要的是，他想打仗。他想穿上一套装备，我是说制服。他想用他最喜欢的词之一，冒险。他想要这些东西如此迫切，以至于一旦美国对西班牙宣战，他就辞去了海军助理部长的职务，从布鲁克斯兄弟定制了一套制服，并自愿作为一名相对卑微的中校参加了第一美国志愿骑兵团。
He helped assemble this ragtag regiment of cowboys, Indians, Ivy League graduates, one genuine Dodge City Marshal and a Jew nicknamed Porkchop. They came to be known as The Rough Riders. Roosevelt described them as "men in whose veins the blood stirred with the same impulse which once sent the Vikings oversea."
他帮助组建了这个由牛仔、印第安人、常春藤盟校毕业生、一名真正的道奇城法警和一个绰号“猪排”的犹太人组成的乌合之众团。他们被称为“粗犷骑手”。罗斯福形容他们是“血管里流淌着同样的冲动的人，这种冲动曾经驱使维京人远渡重洋”。
And how did our Vikings fare? The war was over in four short months. America's first time out in interventionist warfare with the aim of regime change was seen as such a success it became known as The Splendid Little War. Success, hell, if Teddy Roosevelt is to be believed, it was downright fun. In his memoir of his Rough Riders days, he can't stop using the word "delighted."
我们的维京人表现如何？战争在短短四个月内结束。美国第一次以政权更迭为目标的干预性战争被视为如此成功，以至于它被称为“那场辉煌的小战争”。成功，该死，如果西奥多·罗斯福是可信的，那简直是太有趣了。在他关于“粗犷骑手”日子的回忆录中，他不停地使用“高兴”这个词。
All fine until the war ended. The very fact that we call it the Spanish American War hints that Cuban sovereignty was a fairly low priority for the McKinley administration. As the Cuban revolutionary hero Jose Marti worried, "Once the United States is in Cuba, who will drive them out?" After the United States signed a treaty with Spain in 1898, we occupied Cuba for the next five years. In 1902, Cuba became nominally independent thanks to an American act of Congress. It was called the Platt amendment, but a better name for it might have been "Buenos Dias Fidel."
一切都很顺利，直到战争结束。我们称之为“美西战争”的事实暗示了古巴主权在麦金莱政府看来优先级相当低。正如古巴革命英雄何塞·马蒂所担心的，“一旦美国进入古巴，谁来把他们赶走？”在1898年美国与西班牙签署条约后，我们占领了古巴五年。1902年，由于美国国会的一项法案，古巴名义上独立了。它被称为普拉特修正案，但更好的名字可能是“你好，菲德尔”。
It kept Cuba under US protection and gave us the right to intervene in Cuban affairs, which we did for the next half century, re-occupying the country every few years and propping up a series of dictators, crooks and boobs. The last one, a sergeant named Batista, was one of the monsters created in part by American military aid. When the revolution came in 1959, all American businesses in Cuba were nationalized without compensation. "Yankee," said Castro, "go home. And oh, by the way, how do you like them missiles?" Which is to say our clunky post-war policy after the Spanish American War actually led the world to the brink of nuclear annihilation in 1962. And a hundred five years later, Cuba still isn't free.
它使古巴处于美国保护之下，并给了我们干预古巴事务的权利，我们确实在接下来的半个世纪里这样做了，每隔几年就重新占领这个国家，并扶持一系列独裁者、骗子和蠢货。最后一个，一个名叫巴蒂斯塔的中士，是部分由美国军事援助制造的怪物之一。1959年革命到来时，所有在古巴的美国企业都被国有化，没有赔偿。“扬基，”卡斯特罗说，“回家吧。哦，顺便问一下，你们觉得那些导弹怎么样？”这就是说，美西战争后我们笨拙的战后政策实际上在1962年将世界推向了核毁灭的边缘。105年后的今天，古巴依然不自由。
But back at the beginning of the Spanish American War, like at the beginning of this war, Americans understood that their country's role in the world was changing for good. Immediately after, we fought a not-so-splendid war to take over the Philippines that dragged on for years. Theodore Roosevelt became a national hero thanks to his Rough Rider exploits and was President by 1901. He built the Panama Canal, brokered a peace treaty between Russia and Japan, secured Moroccan independence and sent the great white fleet of the US Navy on tour around the globe to show the world that the US was now a power to contend with. Before long, we were in World War I and the whole country was humming the tune "Over There."
但在美西战争初期，就像这场战争初期一样，美国人明白他们国家在世界上的角色正在发生根本性的变化。紧随其后，我们打了一场不太辉煌的战争来接管菲律宾，这场战争持续了多年。西奥多·罗斯福由于他的“粗犷骑手”功绩成为民族英雄，并在1901年成为总统。他修建了巴拿马运河，促成了俄罗斯和日本之间的和平条约，确保了摩洛哥的独立，并派遣美国海军大白舰队环游全球，向世界展示美国现在是一个不可忽视的力量。不久，我们就参加了第一次世界大战，全国都在哼唱“在那边”。
Finally, there's one more side effect of America's first attempt at regime change. The Platt amendment, signed by President McKinley in 1901, required the Cubans to lease land to the US Navy. That base at Guantanamo Bay is currently the home of several hundred Taliban and other prisoners of the War On Terror. I like to believe that if Saddam Hussein is captured, he'll be put in a brig on the USS Theodore Roosevelt and taken to await trial in a cell at Guantanamo Bay.
最后，美国第一次政权更迭尝试还有一个副作用。1901年由麦金莱总统签署的普拉特修正案，要求古巴人将土地租给美国海军。关塔那摩湾基地目前是数百名塔利班和反恐战争囚犯的家园。我喜欢相信，如果萨达姆·侯赛因被捕，他会被关进美国西奥多·罗斯福号航空母舰上的囚室，并被带到关塔那摩湾的一个牢房里等待审判。
Sarah Vowell is author of The Partly Cloudy Patriot and a regular contributor to our program.
莎拉·沃威尔是《部分多云的爱国者》的作者，也是我们节目的常客。
[MUSIC - "THE GULF WAR SONG" BY MOXY FURVOUS]
[音乐 - 莫克西·弗沃斯乐队的《海湾战争之歌》]
Act Five, What Peacetime Forgets About Wartime. In a weekly paper here in Chicago a few years back, The Chicago Reader , a writer named Lee Sandlin wrote a story about what it is that makes wartime different. About the particular psychology of being at war, the things that a country goes through in war that it does not experience any other time. It was a massive historical article. Here's an excerpt, which we ran a few years back but seemed appropriate this weekend. It's read for us by Matt Malloy.
第五幕，和平时期忘记了战争时期。几年前，在芝加哥的一份周报《芝加哥读者报》上，一位名叫李·桑德林的作家写了一个关于什么让战争时期变得不同的故事。关于处于战争中的特殊心理，国家在战争中经历而不在任何其他时间经历的事情。这是一篇宏大的历史文章。以下是摘录，我们在几年前播出过，但这个周末看起来很合适。由马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
Back when the forest still stretched in an unbroken expanse from Scandinavia to the Urals, the Vikings who inhabited its northernmost reaches wrote down their own stories about war. Their legends may have been garish fantasies, cursed rings and enchanted gold and dragon slayers, but when they wrote about battle, they were unsparingly exact. Their sagas still offer the subtlest and most rigorous accounts of the unique psychology of combat.
当森林依然从斯堪的纳维亚延伸到乌拉尔山脉时，居住在最北端的维京人写下了他们自己的战争故事。他们的传说可能是粗俗的幻想、被诅咒的戒指、附魔的黄金和屠龙者，但当他们写到战斗时，他们是不留情面地精确。他们的萨迦仍然提供了关于战斗独特心理的最细微和最严谨的叙述。
They knew that the experience of being on a battlefield is fundamentally different from everything else in life. It simply can't be described with ordinary words so they devised a specialized vocabulary to handle it. Some of their terms will do perfectly well for a world war fought 1,000 years later. The Vikings knew, for instance, that prolonged exposure to combat can goad some men into a state of uncontrolled, psychic fury. They might be the most placid men in the world in peacetime, but on the battlefield they begin to act with the most inexplicable and gratuitous cruelty. They become convinced that they're invincible, above all rules and restraints, literally transformed into supermen and werewolves. The Vikings called such men berserkers.
他们知道，身处战场的体验与生活中其他一切都根本不同。它无法用普通的词汇来描述，所以他们设计了一种专门的词汇来处理它。他们的一些术语对于1000年后打的一场世界大战来说非常完美。例如，维京人知道，长期暴露在战斗中可以刺激一些人进入一种无法控制的、心理上的狂怒状态。他们在和平时期可能是世界上最温和的人，但在战场上，他们开始做出最无法解释和无端的残暴行为。他们变得相信自己是不可战胜的，凌驾于一切规则和约束之上，字面上变成了超人和狼人。维京人称这样的人为“狂战士”。
World War II was filled with instances of ordinary soldiers giving in to berserker behavior. In battle after battle, soldiers on all sides were observed killing wantonly and indiscriminately, defying all orders to stop in a kind of collective blood rage. They were found in every army, even among those that emphasized discipline and humane conduct. American Marines in the Pacific became notorious for their berserker mentality, particularly their profound lack of interest in taking prisoners. In his memoir, a Marine named Eugene Sledge describes once seeing another Marine in a classic berserker state urinating into the open mouth of a dead Japanese soldier.
二战中充满了普通士兵屈服于狂战士行为的例子。在一场又一场战斗中，各方的士兵被观察到肆意和不加区别地杀戮，无视所有停止的命令，处于一种集体的血腥狂怒中。他们出现在每一支军队中，即使在那些强调纪律和人性化行为的军队中也是如此。在太平洋地区的美国海军陆战队员因其狂战士心态而臭名昭著，特别是他们对俘虏的深刻不感兴趣。在回忆录中，一名叫尤金·斯莱奇的海军陆战队员描述了曾经看到另一名海军陆战队员处于经典的狂战士状态，在一名死去的日本士兵敞开的嘴里撒尿。
Another Viking term was fay. People now understand it to mean effeminate. Previously it meant odd, and before that, uncanny, fairy-like. That was back when fairyland was the most sinister place people could imagine. The old Norse word meant doomed. It was used to refer to an eerie mood that would come over people in battle, a kind of transcendent despair.
另一个维京术语是“fay”。人们现在理解它意味着娘娘腔。以前它意味着古怪，再早之前，意味着不可思议、像仙女一样。那是在仙境被人们能想象到的最险恶的地方的时候。古老的诺尔斯语意味着“注定”。它被用来指代一种在战斗中笼罩人们的诡异情绪，一种超然的绝望。
The state was described vividly by an American reporter, Tom Lee, in the midst of the desperate battle of Peleliu in the South Pacific. "He felt something inside of himself, some instinctive psychic urge to keep himself alive, finally collapse at the sight of one more dead soldier in the ruins of a tropical jungle." Lee wrote, "He seemed so quiet and empty and past all the small things a man could love or hate. I suddenly knew I no longer had to defend my beating heart against the stillness of death. There was no defense."
这种状态由美国记者汤姆·李在南太平洋贝里琉岛绝望的战斗中生动地描述。他在看到热带丛林废墟中又一名死去的士兵时，感觉到内心深处某种本能的心理冲动要让自己活下去，最终崩溃了。李写道：“他显得如此安静、空虚，超越了男人所能爱或恨的所有小事。我突然知道我不再需要为我跳动的心脏抵御死亡的寂静。没有防线。”
"There was no defense." That's fay. People go through battle willing the bullet to miss, the shelling to stop, the heart to go on beating. And then they feel something in their soul surrender. And they give in to everything they'd been most afraid of. It's like a glimpse of eternity. Whether the battle is lost or won, it will never end. It has wholly taken over the soul. Sometimes, men say afterward that the most terrifying moment of any battle is seeing a fay look on the faces of the soldiers standing next to them.
“没有防线。”这就是“fay”。人们经历战斗，祈祷子弹射偏，炮击停止，心脏继续跳动。然后他们感到灵魂中的某种东西投降了。他们屈服于他们最害怕的一切。就像瞥见了永恒。无论战斗是输是赢，它永远不会结束。它已经完全占领了灵魂。有时，人们事后说，任何战斗中最可怕的时刻是看到身边士兵脸上那种“fay”的表情。
Fayness might also explain the deepest mystery of the war, why the surrender everybody expected never came. The Germans and Japanese refused to surrender even though they knew the war was lost. Not until the last days of the war did either government even consider a negotiated settlement, not until they had absolutely nothing left to negotiate with. But then that's the point, a rational calculation of the odds is a calculation via the logic of peace.
“fayness”也可能解释战争中最深的谜团，为什么每个人预期的投降从未到来。德国人和日本人拒绝投降，尽管他们知道战争已经输了。直到战争的最后几天，两国政府甚至才考虑谈判解决，直到他们绝对没有任何东西可以协商。但这就是关键点，对胜算的理性计算是通过和平逻辑进行的计算。
War has a different logic. A kind of vast fayness can infect a military bureaucracy when it's losing a war, a collective slippage of the sense of objective truth in the face of approaching disaster. In the later years of World War II, the bureaucracies of the Axis behind the lines gradually retreated into a dreamy, paper war where they were on the brink of a triumphant reversal of fortune.
战争有不同的逻辑。当军事官僚机构在输掉一场战争时，一种巨大的“fayness”可以感染它，在面对临近的灾难时，对客观真理感的集体丧失。在第二次世界大战的后期，轴心国后方的官僚机构逐渐退缩到一场梦幻般的纸面战争中，在那里他们处于胜利扭转局势的边缘。
Not everybody succumbed to these fantasies, but those who understood how hopeless the situation really was also knew that defeat would mean accountability. And they had a reasonably good idea of what would happen to them if they were ever forced to answer for what they'd done. This is the dreadful logic that comes to control a lot of wars.
并非每个人都屈服于这些幻想，但那些了解局势真实多么绝望的人也知道，失败意味着追责。而且他们很清楚，如果他们被迫为自己的所作所为负责，会发生什么。这是控制许多战争的恐怖逻辑。
The American Civil War is another example. The losers prolong their agony as much as possible because they're convinced the alternative is worse. Meanwhile, the winners, who might earlier have accepted a compromise peace, become so maddened by the refusal of their enemies to stop fighting that they see no reason to settle for anything less than absolute victory.
美国内战是另一个例子。失败者尽可能延长痛苦，因为他们确信选择更糟。与此同时，获胜者可能早先接受了妥协和平，但被敌人的拒绝停止战斗所激怒，以至于他们看不到除了绝对胜利之外还能接受任何其他结果的理由。
In this sense, the later course of World War II was typical. It kept on escalating no matter what the strategic situation was. And it grew progressively more violent and uncontrollable long after the outcome was a foregone conclusion. The difference was that no other war had ever had such deep reserves of violence to draw upon
在这个意义上，二战的后期进程是典型的。无论战略局势如何，它都在不断升级。在结果早已成定局后，它变得越来越暴力和不可控。区别在于没有其他战争曾经拥有如此深厚的暴力储备。
The Vikings would have understood all this. They didn't have a word for the prolongation of war long past any rational goal. They just knew that that's what always happened. It's the subject of their longest and greatest saga, the Brennu-Njals saga, or the saga of Njal burned alive. The saga describes a trivial feud in back-country Iceland that keeps escalating for reasons nobody can understand or resolve until it engulfs the whole of northern Europe. Provocation after fresh provocation, peace conference after failed peace conference, it has its own momentum, like a hurricane of carnage. For the Vikings, this was the essence of war. It's a mystery that comes out of nowhere and grows for reasons nobody can control until it shakes the whole world apart.
维京人会明白所有这些。他们没有一个词来形容战争远远超过任何理性目标。他们只是知道这就是一直发生的事情。这是他们最长和最伟大的萨迦的主题，“布伦努-恩雅尔萨迦”，或“活活烧死的恩雅尔萨迦”。萨迦描述了冰岛偏远地区的一场琐碎争斗，为了没人能理解或解决的原因不断升级，直到它吞没了整个北欧。一次又一次的新挑衅，一次又一次失败的和平会议，它有自己的动量，就像一场屠杀的飓风。对于维京人来说，这就是战争的本质。这是一个来自虚无的谜团，因没人能控制的原因而增长，直到它撼动整个世界。
This was the course of World War II from the fall of 1944 on. After the Allies at last acknowledged that despite the decisive victories of the previous summer, the Axis was never going to surrender. That was when the Allies changed their strategy. They set out to make an Axis surrender irrelevant.
这就是从1944年秋天开始的二战进程。在盟军最终承认尽管在前一个夏天取得了决定性胜利，但轴心国永远不会投降之后。那时盟军改变了战略。他们着手使轴心国的投降变得无关紧要。
From that winter into the next spring, the civilians of Germany and Japan were helpless before a new Allied campaign of systematic aerial bombardment. The air forces and air defense systems of the Axis were in ruins by then. Allied planes flew where they pleased, day or night, 500 at a time, then 1,000 at a time, indiscriminately dumping avalanches of bombs on every city and town in Axis territory that had a military installation or a railroad yard or a factory. There was no precedent, even in this war, for the destruction on so ferocious a scale. It was the largest berserker rage in history.
从那个冬天到下一个春天，德国和日本的平民面对一场新的盟军系统性空中轰炸运动束手无策。到那时，轴心国的空军和防空系统已经沦为废墟。盟军飞机随心所欲地飞行，日夜不停，一次500架，然后一次1000架，不加区别地在轴心国领土上每一个有军事设施或铁路枢纽或工厂的城市和城镇倾泻雪崩般的炸弹。即使在这场战争中，也没有如此凶猛规模破坏的先例。这是历史上最大规模的狂战士愤怒。
The Allies routinely dropped incendiary bombs in such great numbers that they created firestorms in cities throughout the Axis countries. These weren't simply large fires. A true firestorm is a freak event, where a large central core of flame heats up explosively to more than 1,500 degrees and everything within it goes up by spontaneous combustion. Buildings erupt, the water boils out of rivers and canals, the asphalt on the pavement ignites. Immense intake vortices spring up around the core and begin sucking in oxygen from the surrounding atmosphere at hurricane speeds. The Allied raids reduced cities in minutes to miles of smoldering debris. Hundreds of thousands of people were killed, about 20% of them children. Tens of thousands suffocated because in the area around a fire storm, there's no oxygen left to breathe.
盟军例行投下大量的燃烧弹，在轴心国国家的城市中制造了火风暴。这些不仅仅是大型火灾。真正的火风暴是一种离奇事件，大量的中央火焰核心爆炸性地加热到超过1500度，其内部的一切都会自发燃烧。建筑物喷发，水从河流和运河中沸腾出来，路面的沥青起火。巨大的摄入涡流在核心周围涌现，并开始以飓风般的速度从周围的大气中吸入氧气。盟军的突袭在几分钟内将城市变成了数英里的阴燃残骸。数十万人丧生，其中约20%是儿童。数万人窒息，因为在火风暴周围的区域，没有氧气可以呼吸。
Out of idle curiosity, I've have been asking friends, people my age and younger, what they know about war. War stories they've heard from their families, facts they've learned in school, stray images that may have stuck with them from old TV documentaries. I wasn't interested in the fine points of strategy, but the key events, the biggest moments, the things people at the time had thought would live on as long as there was anybody around to remember the past.
出于闲暇好奇，我一直在问朋友，我这个年龄和更年轻的人，他们对战争了解什么。他们从家人那里听到的战争故事，在学校学到的事实，从旧电视纪录片中可能留在脑海中的零散图像。我并不关心战略的细节，而是关键事件，最大的时刻，当时人们认为只要有人记得过去，就会流传下去的事情。
To give everybody a big enough target, I asked about World War II. I figured people had to know the basics. World War II isn't exactly easy to miss. It was the largest war ever fought, the largest single event in history. So what did the people I asked know about the war? Nobody could tell me the first thing about it. Once they got past who won, they almost drew a blank. All they knew were those big, totemic names, Pearl Harbor, D-Day, Auschwitz , Hiroshima. The rest was gone. Kasserine, Leyte Gulf, Corregidor, Falaise, the Ardennes didn't provoke a glimmer of recognition. They might as well have been off-ramps on some exotic interstate.
为了给每个人一个足够大的目标，我问了第二次世界大战。我想人们一定知道基本知识。第二次世界大战并不容易被遗忘。这是有史以来打过的最大的战争，历史上最大的单一事件。那么我问的人对战争了解什么呢？没有人能告诉我关于它的第一件事。一旦超过了谁赢了，他们几乎一片空白。他们所知道的只是那些巨大的、图腾般的名字，珍珠港、诺曼底登陆、奥斯威辛、广岛。其余的都消失了。卡塞林、莱特湾、科雷希多、法莱斯、阿登战役没有激起一丝认知的火花。它们就像某个异国他乡州际公路上的出口。
What had happened, for instance, at one of the war's biggest battles, the Battle of Midway? "It was in the Pacific. There was something about aircraft carriers. Wasn't there a movie about it?" A couple of people were even surprised to hear that Midway Airport in Chicago was named after the battle, though they'd walked past the ugly commemorative sculpture in the concourse so many times.
例如，在战争最大的战斗之一——中途岛战役中发生了什么？“是在太平洋。有一些关于航空母舰的事情。不是有一部关于它的电影吗？”几个人甚至很惊讶地听说芝加哥的中途岛机场是以这场战斗命名的，尽管他们多次走过大厅里丑陋的纪念雕塑。
All in all, this was a dispiriting exercise. The astonishing events of that morning at Midway, the quote "fatal five minutes on which the war and the fate of the world had hung," had been reduced to a plaque nobody reads at an airport with a vaguely puzzling name midway between Chicago and nowhere at all.
总而言之，这是一次令人沮丧的练习。那个上午在中途岛发生的惊人事件，即“战争和世界命运悬于其上的决定性五分钟”，被简化为机场里没人读的牌匾，机场的名字模糊地令人困惑，位于芝加哥和虚无之间。
Is it that the war was 50 years ago and nobody cares anymore about what happened in the past? Maybe so, but I think what my little survey really demonstrates is how vast the gap is between the experience of war and the experience of peace. And there's another and simpler reason the war has been forgotten. People wanted to forget it. It had gone on for so many years, had destroyed so much, had killed so many. Most US casualties were in the final year of fighting.
是因为战争是50年前的事情，没人再关心过去发生的事情了吗？也许如此，但我认为我的小调查真正证明的是战争体验与和平体验之间的鸿沟有多大。战争被遗忘还有另一个更简单的原因。人们想忘记它。它持续了这么多年，摧毁了这么多，杀死了这么多。大多数美国伤亡是在战斗的最后一年。
When it came to an end, people were glad to be rid of everything about it. That was what surprised commentators about the public reaction in America and Europe when the news broke that Germany and then Japan had at last surrendered. In the wild celebrations that followed, nobody crowed, "Our enemies are destroyed." Nobody even yelled, "We've won." What they all said instead was, "The war is over." That was the message that flashed around the world in the summer of 1945. "The war is over. The war is over."
当它结束时，人们很高兴摆脱关于它的一切。这就是当德国和日本最终投降的消息传来时，公众对美国和欧洲公众反应感到惊讶的地方。在随后的狂热庆祝活动中，没人欢呼“我们的敌人被消灭了”。没人喊“我们赢了”。他们取而代之说的是，“战争结束了”。那是1945年夏天在全世界闪烁的消息。“战争结束了。战争结束了。”
Matt Malloy, reading an article by Lee Sandlin that appeared in The Chicago Reader.
马特·马洛伊，朗读出现在《芝加哥读者报》上李·桑德林的一篇文章。
[MUSIC - "REMEMBER PEARL HARBOR" BY SAMMY KAYE AND HIS ORCHESTRA WITH THE GLEE CLUB]
[音乐 - 萨米·凯和他的管弦乐队及合唱团的《记住珍珠港》]
Act Six. Now this story from a preventive act of war committed 3,200 years ago in modern day Turkey, not far from Iraq. Or anyway that's how the story goes. After the Trojan War, this bloody, ten year war that left Troy devastated, the Greeks, who won that war, felt that they could not leave Troy unless they killed all the children of the King. They assumed that one of his kids might some day grow up to lead the Trojans in a war of revenge against them. One little grandson was still left, maybe three or four years old. And one of the Greeks, Ulysses, goes to the boy's mom to talk her into handing him over so that neither country will have to face another war. Needless to say, she's not too keen on that idea.
第六幕。现在这个故事来自3200年前现代土耳其发生的一场预防性战争，离伊拉克不远。或者总之故事是这样说的。特洛伊战争之后，这场血腥的十年战争让特洛伊荒废了，赢得战争的希腊人觉得除非他们杀掉国王所有的孩子，否则他们不能离开特洛伊。他们认为他的一两个孩子有一天可能会长大，领导特洛伊人对他们进行复仇战争。还有一个小孙子留着，可能三四岁大。其中一个希腊人尤利西斯去找男孩的妈妈说服她交出孩子，这样两国都不必面对另一场战争。不用说，她不太热衷于这个主意。
Mary Zimmerman is a Chicago director. She won the MacArthur Genius Grant. She won last year's Tony for Best Director. And she's now directing the play The Trojan Women , written 2,000 years ago, telling this story. She says that from the play's opening, it's hard not to think about very recent events.
玛丽·齐默尔曼是一位芝加哥导演。她赢得了麦克阿瑟天才奖。她赢得了去年的托尼奖最佳导演奖。她现在正在导演2000年前写的戏剧《特洛伊妇女》，讲述这个故事。她说从戏剧开头开始，就很难不想到最近发生的事件。
It starts out with language that recalls our own ground zero really, really closely. And so we have this profound identification with the victims in the play to begin with. But then, when the aggressors come on, their language sounds so much like the language of our own administration that this strange flip happens.
它以回想起我们自己的地面零点真的非常、非常紧密的语言开始。因此，我们一开始就对剧中的受害者产生了深刻的认同感。但随后，当侵略者出现时，他们的语言听起来非常像我们自己政府的语言，这种奇怪的翻转发生了。
But at the beginning, Hecuba is lying in this pile of rubble and she says-- and this is the really killer part to me-- "Never did we imagine the ground we stood on would give away, shudder, gape open and swallow all we had and were. We supposed that gods had built the city. We believed ourselves to be safe. Nothing is safe for sure but ruin itself. In billows of black smoke, the sky is obliterated. Daylight itself is in mourning. The air is thick with ashes and a foul smell like that of cooking meat, except we know it's human flesh, and gag and try to hold our breath."
但在开头，赫卡芭躺在这一堆瓦砾中，她说——这对我来说真是最感人的部分——“我们从未想象过我们站立的地面会崩塌、震颤、裂开，吞噬我们所有的一切。我们以为是神建造了这座城市。我们相信自己是安全的。除了废墟本身，没有什么肯定是安全的。在滚滚黑烟中，天空被湮灭。光天化日之下也在哀悼。空气中充满了灰烬和一种难闻的味道，就像煮肉一样，除了我们知道那是人肉， gag并试图屏住呼吸。”
And then Ulysses comes on from the other side. And he's there on a mission to basically kill a little boy who the Greeks don't want to grow up and become a leader who will start a war against them. So he's on this sort of preventive war mission. And when he shows up, he's using language like, "You have to give him over to us. He threatens the peace. His life is a danger. We cannot allow it to continue to undermine the entire region's collective security."
然后尤利西斯从另一边出现。他出现在这里是为了执行基本上杀死一个小男孩的任务，希腊人不想让他长大成为一个发动反战战争的领导人。所以他执行的是这种预防性战争任务。当他出现时，他使用的是诸如“你必须把他交给我们。他威胁和平。他的生命是一个危险。我们不能允许它继续破坏整个地区的集体安全。”之类的语言。
Yes, it very clearly is a preemptive strike.
是的，这非常清楚是一次先发制人的打击。
I have to say reading the text of this, what's most striking is how sad Ulysses is to have to do it. He's the one who has to go out and get the kid from the kid's mother.
我不得不说阅读这些文字，最引人注目的是尤利西斯不得不这样做是多么难过。他是那个不得不出去从母亲那里带走孩子的人。
He is sad. He knows it's a disgusting job he has. But he knows he has to do it, and he's done it before. He knows it's his lot. The war machine is rolling over him as it's rolling over everyone else and forcing him into being this kind of person.
他是难过的。他知道这是一项令人作呕的工作。但他知道他必须做，他以前做过。他知道这是他的命。战争机器像碾压其他人一样碾压他，强迫他成为这种人。
It's interesting. As the whole discussion goes on when finally she gives the boy over to him, and then says goodbye to him, she pretty much admits that he's right.
很有趣。当整个讨论继续进行时，当她最终把他交给孩子，然后和他告别时，她基本上承认他是对的。
Yeah, she does.
是的，她是的。
That if he left her [INAUDIBLE]
如果他留下她[不清楚]
--complex about the play and what the Greeks understood about war is that it doesn't end. And I feel that although Andromache really does hope that the little boy could grow up--
——关于这出戏以及希腊人对战争的理解是它永远不会结束。我觉得虽然安德罗玛刻确实希望小男孩能长大——
And lead them to victory.
并领导他们走向胜利。
And lead them to victory. She also makes the argument, admittedly to try and save his life, look, his spirit is broken. "In a lifetime," she says, "could he rebuild, rearm? He's seen his father dragged through the dust. What kind of spirit do you think this little boy has?"
并领导他们走向胜利。她也提出了这个论点，虽然是为了挽救他的生命，看，他的精神已经崩溃了。“在一生中，”她说，“他能重建，重新武装吗？他见过他的父亲在尘土中被拖行。你认为这个小男孩有什么样的精神？”
So this goes on, this discussion. The play proceeds. And then when the Greeks finally kill the little boy-- one of the things that's interesting reading it is that they are just as wrecked about it as the Trojans.
所以这继续下去，讨论继续。戏剧继续。然后当希腊人最终杀死小男孩时——阅读它的有趣点之一是他们对它也像特洛伊人一样被摧毁。
They're completely wrecked by it.
他们被它完全摧毁了。
So let me ask you to read the speech. A messenger comes in, reports on what has happened.
那么让我请你读这段演讲。一位信使进来，报告了发生的事情。
"Through the crowd Ulysses makes his way, leading by the hand the boy who follows in confidence. The crowd is hushed, solemn, and here and there one can see tears that fall from brimming eyes. Ulysses recites the prayers Calcus instructed, summoning gods to witness what is being done. But the boy, knowing what then must come, of his own free will departs from the script to take command himself and steps abruptly out and over and into thin air to fall and plunge in an instant down through the delicate surface of the Earth to rejoin Priam in the gloomy kingdom below."
“通过人群，尤利西斯走过，领着自信地跟在后面的男孩的手。人群是静谧、庄严的，在这里和那里可以看到泪水从充满泪水的眼中落下。尤利西斯背诵卡尔库斯指示的祈祷文，召唤众神见证正在做的事情。但男孩，知道接下来必须发生什么，自愿脱离剧本，自己指挥，突然走出去，踏入稀薄的空气中，坠落并瞬间 plunging 穿过地球脆弱的表面，重新加入下面阴暗王国的普里阿摩斯。”
The messenger goes on, "After the boy had fallen, the throng of Greeks still weeping for what had been done in their name, turned to Achilles' tomb by Roecian waters, with what thoughts who can say? The future threat, if ever there was a threat, had disappeared. Would another death propitiate the whims or offend the gods as it would seem to offend any sane person watching? Greeks and Trojans weep together, appalled as the blood soaks into the thirsty earth that drinks the copious gore until it is gone. Thus was the rite performed.
信使继续说，“男孩坠落后，一大群希腊人仍在为以他们的名义所做的事哭泣，转向罗西恩水域的阿喀琉斯之墓，谁能说出是什么想法？未来的威胁，如果曾经有威胁的话，已经消失了。另一个死亡会平息众神的突发奇想或冒犯众神，就像它似乎冒犯任何观看的理智的人一样吗？希腊人和特洛伊人一起哭泣，震惊地看着血液渗入干渴的地球，饮用大量的鲜血直到它消失。就这样仪式完成了。”
Mary Zimmerman. Her production of The Trojan Woman opens at The Goodman Theatre in Chicago in April.
玛丽·齐默尔曼。她的《特洛伊妇女》作品将于四月在芝加哥的古德曼剧院开演。
Our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook and Starlee Kine. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Katy Adone.
我们的节目今天由温迪·多尔和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克和斯塔利·基恩协助。托德·巴赫曼和凯蒂·阿多内提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who wondered--
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他想知道——
Is Sacajawea a province?
萨卡加维亚是一个省吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories from This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来《美国生活》的更多故事。
What about Mandingo?
曼丁戈呢？
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。